POSSIBILITY THAT I MIGHT DIE.
SINCE I'VE NEVER BEEN
VERY FOND OF MY FAMILY,
I DECIDED TO DO
THE RESPONSIBLE THING
AND GET MY AFFAIRS IN ORDER
BY LETTING YOU,
MY FANS, WRITE MY WILL
IN OUR LATEST INSTALLMENT
OF TWITTEN BY.
HERE'S HOW I STARTED IT:
"PLEASE, BE COMPASSIONATE
WHEN WRITING MY WILL.
"I, DANIEL TOSH, HEREBY...
"BEING OF QUESTIONABLE MIND
AND SEXUAL ORIENTATION,
BEQUEATH MY DILDO COLLECTION
TO MY OWN BUTTHOLE."
I WILL LET YOU KNOW THAT
WITHIN ABOUT THREE HOURS,
I RECEIVED CLOSE
TO 3,000 OR 4,000 REFERENCES
TO WHAT I WOULD DO
WITH MY DILDOS,
ET CETERA, ET CETERA.
THE REASON WE CHOSE THIS ONE
IS BECAUSE IT WAS THE FIRST ONE
THAT CAME IN
IN UNDER EIGHT SECONDS.
"I GIVE FORTH MY FIVE GROW
HOUSES ACROSS THE UNITED STATES
TO THOSE LITTLE KIDS
IN AFRICA WHO SMOKIN' ON SWAG."
[laughs]
"DONATE MY BODY
TO ANY GAY SCIENCE.
"I DONATE EVERYTHING TO
THE PATRICK SWAYZE FOUNDATION
"IN SUPPORT OF ASS CANCER,
KARATE, AND SHITTY DANCING.
"WHAT IS HALF OF NOTHING?
LEAVE THAT TO MY MOM.
"MY TELEVISION SHOW SHALL
GO TO CHRIS ROCK
"BECAUSE HIS FIVE-MINUTE
GUEST SPOT HAD BETTER RATINGS
"THAN MY FIRST
TWO SEASONS COMBINED.
"WAFFLES, WAFFLES,
CRISPY, GOLDEN WAFFLES...
"WILL BE STUFFED
AND MOUNTED...
"LIKE YOUR MOM.
HA, HA, HA,
AFTER DEATH BURN."
"HEREBY GIVE MY COLLECTION
OF CELEBRITY SEMEN SAMPLES
"TO BEN AND JERRY'S
FOR A NEW SERIES OF FLAVORS
CALLED TOSH.0FACES."
I KNOW A SCHOOL TEACHER
THAT WOULD LOVE THAT FLAVOR.
I DO, I DO.
HE WAS MY FAVORITE TEACHER.
HE WAS TOTALLY MISUNDERSTOOD.
"BLAH, BLAH, BLAH, BLAH, BLAH,
BLAH...SOMETHING RACIST.
"HASHTAG, HIGH FASHION.
"I BEQUEATH MY SCARF COLLECTION
TO NORV TURNER
SO HE CAN FINALLY COVER UP
THAT GROSS SCROTUM NECK."
YOU THINK NORV WAS AT HOME,
GOING TONIGHT, "OH, TWITTEN BY.
I'M GOING TO GET A SHOT."
"I GIVE UP ON WILL WRITING.
THIS SHIT IS TOO HARD.
"I LEAVE NOTHING TO NOBODY.
BURY MY SHIT WITH ME.
"IF YOU WANT NICE THINGS,
GET YOUR OWN.
DON'T WAIT FOR ME TO DIE."
I'M GOING TO GET
THAT NOTARIZED THIS WEEK.